good afternoon welcome to uh you know
sort of the second half of the tutorial
day at pi yet I hope everyone is having
a good conference so I'm going to give a
quick set of slides just maybe ten
minutes or so this a little bit of a
rehash I did give a talk at Syfy about a
month ago and this is a little bit
similar to that I'm just going to speed
through it though because most of the
tutorial is hands-on exercises we've got
some notebooks and I'm going to go
through some demonstrations and examples
there and then you guys are going to get
a chance hopefully to work on that as
well so if you haven't you might try to
go and install ipython notebook the
easiest way to do that is probably to
install anaconda if you need any help
there are a few continuum folks I think
in the audience and also a mic another
one over here is well new continuum folk
person who can help you out a bit but
we'll just wait what's over and I'm
going to be coming out in the audience
to during the exercises that folks need
help to sort of get people running so
without any sort of further introduction
let's go ahead and get started so if you
would let me give you a chance this is
actually the link to the day I Python
notebooks going to use for the tutorial
this bitly link so I'll give everyone
just a moment to follow that it's
actually on the env viewer website so
NBD viewers a website that allows you to
host statically ipython notebooks that
have you know whatever kind of content
so there's all kinds of projects
matplotlib and flatly and sk learn all
kinds of projects have example notebooks
up on NB viewer so if you just google NB
view or bouquet you probably also find
it or put it in bing or put it in
whatever search engine you want to you
should be able to find that but this
link should go straight to the bouquet
NB viewer website give everyone just a
minute
okay so everyone had a chance to follow
that link and get to the notebooks okay
good so first just want to talk a little
bit about you know what we're bouquets
at today and where it's sort of going so
if you're not familiar first of all
bouquets and plotting library allows you
to generate interactive sort of rich and
innovative visualizations in the browser
buts do it from Python really without
having to write any you know too much
JavaScript or any JavaScript and so
that's really a nice thing we've been
working on it for quite a while now
we've had a lot of features in the last
year or so so just a quick update on
where we are people been asking for
things like selection tool is lasso and
poly and you know crosshair inspectors
and hover tools that work with lines all
that's been added le that also done a
sort of visual design pass right so if
you have been following bouquet for a
while you might remember some early
attempts at sort of having a toolbar and
things look pretty clunky and they look
a lot better now we're still working on
that we're continuing to sort of work on
the visual design aspect of bouquet
Doc's there's a lot better Doc support
now people have asked about that we you
know you asked then we heard that call
so the reference guide is one hundred
percent complete we're still going to be
working on improving that with for
instance like an explorer style sort of
explore or an object Explorer lets you
in real time in the documentation sort
of explore what attributes you can
change that's not quite there yet but we
do have auto-generated reference socks
that are automatically filled out and we
also have a much expanded user guide let
me actually jump over to that right
quick because you'll be spending
hopefully some time there during this
tutorial so so yeah so this is well
first off this is the envy viewer side
just so you can see it and if you go
down to the bottom there is tutorial and
so this is the notebooks we're going to
be using we're going to be using the
basic plotting high-level charts we'll
see how far we get we're just going to
keep working through those notebooks but
if you go to the NB viewer site all of
those are the ones we're going to be
using and then the users guide i just
wanted to point out again this is where
we'll be spending a lot of time today
hopefully looking up things so all the
users guide has information about all
the different visual properties all the
knobs and dials that you can turn and
switches you can flip but it also has
live plots with the code examples there
so for instance how to change the title
of the back
round or all kinds of things about the
glyphs and and so all of these things
are there with the actual code samples
that generated them in line in the docs
and these are real live you know bouquet
bouquet plot so hopefully that'll be a
useful resource for you there's a lot of
other sections in the user's guide as
well so hopefully this is not the end of
the journey for our docs but definitely
I think an improvement that'll be very
valuable for folks okay so we also just
recently added a new static or a method
dad really rich interactions to static
documents by static documents I mean
something that has the data embedded in
it you could just email it to someone
there's no sort of server required so we
had a mechanism for adding very small
little JavaScript callback so we sort of
backed away a little bit from the idea
of not having to write any JavaScript to
the idea that well if you don't mind
writing a few lines here and there you
can get some really sophisticated
interactions without having to need any
any further sort of server support so
we'll see some examples of that during
the tutorial today and then finally I
just should mention our bouquet as well
so the way bouquets architected it's
actually really easy to write well it's
def possible to write language bindings
for it in any language right it's just a
declarative jason interface so you can
have scala or lua bindings have been
created Julia someone created Julia
bindings last year Ryan Haven one of our
DARPA collaborators has started working
on our bouquet so that's available as
well so we're very excited love to see
you know bouquet available in lots of
languages certainly we're heavily
invested in Python and continue until
we've worked very very much on that so
just a quick recap of the present day so
this was about a year ago just to sort
of show you what we're coming from I was
you know really impressed by these
numbers a year ago I thought that's
pretty amazing all the combined Conda
and ipi downloads but you know today
this i took this screenshot today and
this is almost 35,000 installs a month
now I know that those numbers are
probably inflated somewhat by continuous
integration installs and things like
that but it's still very humbling to see
the interest in the in the adoption that
bookcase added so hopefully we'll keep
making it better and better quick slide
just to show the reason we can do that
is because we have a great team of
people working you know not everyone
here is working full time on você but a
lot of folks putting in various efforts
you know working on design working on
client projects working on the core
functionality a lot of those folks you
know put in some just amazing work and
so that's the reason we were able to
move these things forward so what do we
have today so I mentioned this
a callback mechanism and this is
actually pretty cool we'll see this in
the tutorial so I'm not going to pause
to do it now but this is a reproduction
of Hans Rosling graph from the TED talk
sort of several years ago where he was
showing over time you know what was the
sort of the trends in sort of this
measured you know childbirths fertility
rates versus sort of life expectancy for
a variety of different countries around
the world and so we can reproduce this
in a static book applaud and not too
much code and again there's no sort of
extra server or any kind of program
needed it's just an HTML file with some
JavaScript it gets generated for you
anyway that's again that's there now and
actually we want to make this even
simpler we want to take you know the
lessons we learned the kind of things
people create so we can actually
encapsulate those into the callbacks
that are spell in Python that don't
require any JavaScript or someday the
dream would be able to write pythons are
callbacks directly in Python I think
this is a really interesting problem so
if anyone here knows sort of about you
know trans palacian from a languages two
languages and wants to help out that we
great I'd love to work on this i just
don't really have enough time but if you
think it's interesting problem too we
definitely are always looking for new
contributors anyway the users guide has
a lot more information about all of
these callbacks and again we'll see some
examples in the tutorial another example
that's kind of interesting is the
spectrogram example showed this off a
year ago but we wanted to show it again
at site by this year because I wanted to
just show that you know we really sort
of added a lot of functionality for
being able to embed bouquet plots
however you want whatever you know makes
sense and so here's an example of that
running and this is actually so this
demo just in case you don't know it's
actually reading the mic on my
microphone it's doing a Fourier
transform of the data and making that
nice waterfall plot you get a little
power spectrum that gets generated there
and and so what's different from the you
know this you know this year versus last
year and sort of why I want to revisit
it is that sorry you know is that we've
made it much much easier to completely
customize the templating and the
embedding right so you can take a
bouquet plot and put it in your own you
know web application you know if you're
serving that from you know is or Django
or fly ask or pyramid or whatever you're
using you can certainly embed bouquet
plots very flexibly in that the
performance enhancements obviously too
if you
watch the video that I you know I showed
it the first time sort of maybe had some
stuttering and we've made some pretty
nice performance enhancement so we're
still working on that but definitely
streaming is a little bit better but the
main difference is that almost all it's
written in Python now so the original
sort of demonstration I showed off a
year ago is maybe 600 lines of coffee
scripts it's kind of cool but maybe not
the sort of thing you'd actually want
have to write and now it's drastically
reduced and it's mostly in Python
there's still a little bit of JavaScript
to help make that work but we keep
pushing towards making that number zero
and that's so that's why I like to show
this app is because it kind of is a
proxy for a lot of things we want to be
able to do with bouquet and sort of it
moving it forward moves the broader
goals of a bouquet forward as well
another example here can't really show
this one off this is in use by armed MX
team or it can put together by a mimic
steam it has a lot of back in part so
it's hard me to demo live but I've got a
little video that sort of shows it often
you know this just shows some
capabilities of creating these nice
dashboards so you can have these hover
tools that drill down into data you can
have the ability to have these you know
pop ups you can have the ability to turn
on and off data fields you know using
the the selections and the clicks down
there and so the main thing though well
first off this is called the feet the
financial event analysis tool and it's
again it's being evaluated by some of
the DARPA collaborators we work with but
the main thing that I want to emphasize
is that it's just it uses bouquets 092
you know or 091 actually when that was
written out of the box right there's no
sort of special features or vapor where
we didn't have to have a branch or
anything like that to do it that's just
straight ahead bouquet 09 like someone
actually by the way bouquets 092 was
released I think this morning so feel
free to do you know Conda update bouquet
or pip update bouquet and you can get
that newest version another example just
the kind of thing you can do with
bouquet this example is kind of cool if
I have it running so this is actually
running there's a cloud server somewhere
a simple flat server that has about a
five big data cube and so i can actually
if i select the right tool like a box
ooh you know go ahead and select an area
here and then i can get progressive
refinement right so i can interactively
sort of zoom and move through this data
cube and and half things update and you
know sort of showed things like this
before as well but again what's
different sort of now to today is that
it's right you could actually run it
today as opposed to me showing something
off this is
the script that I ran to make that
happen and actually as you can see a lot
of it's actually the sort of JavaScript
callback in the middle and there's too
much about it so we're still working on
making that even less but it's still a
very small amount of code to be able to
sort of interactively you know move
through these sort of hdf or whatever
kind of data cube you might have the
flat server was also very short of
straight ahead to right to ask I'm going
to skip that in the sake of time a few
words though about what's coming up just
to close so people have asked for sort
of math taks we're working on that we
think we've identified the technology
that will help us do that this basically
k-tec ercot tech it's the Khan Academy's
a version of math text and so we're
looking at integrating that also looking
at static and headless SVG output the
long-term plan for that is absolutely to
use npl I think that's probably not
gonna be ready until maybe next year
sometime and so in the short term will
probably have something based maybe on
kiro that can let you get static output
working on new higher level charts and
faceting some of the team members Fabio
applied or Nick Roth are going to be
diving into that pretty soon also
validation just easier to get error
messages you know the the way bouquets
architected this idea of putting these
models together and this Jason together
you know for you to make this graph is
really nice but sometimes it's possible
to put things together in the wrong
order and so we have nice validation
error messages now that can tell you
when something is going wrong some other
stuff that's coming up we're looking at
some authoring tools people talk about
you know how do I make apps talk about
like shiny and things like that and so
here's this preview of sort of a develop
mode I don't have a running right at the
moment but this video will play I guess
I don't have well the idea here is you
can actually edit this live document in
the editor and as soon as you say that
the plot gets reloaded so it's a really
fast iteration cycle you know you can
just change the colors or change what
you want you can see the output sort of
immediately over there it's a nice way
to iterate based directly on the Python
code and so that's the sort of thing we
can integrate into this authoring tool
that we're currently working on that'll
be open source as well let's see okay so
last thing is we're also working on
updating and making the server easier to
use and sort of simplifying we're trying
to take some lessons that we've learned
from from it and make it simpler and
smaller really this is what we want to
make it and I know that's a lot of words
up there but the idea is we want to be
able to have Python objects and models
that we can reflect into the browser and
that can really be a platform for a lot
of things it allow us to one to shrink
the client library this book HSS maybe
growing a little bit large we want to
split it up but also let people to do
all kinds of interesting and novel
things without having to rely on us or
without having to put them into the core
library so all of that said we also
pushing on some of the language bindings
in the coming year WebGL this I can
actually show off this was merged into
dev 10 just about a week ago so bring
that up should have this open so this
was a clustering with SK learn four
plots each of these i think is about
50,000 points this was all Mark Lyons
been working on this for us here we go
oh you know what I deleted things of
course live demos that's what i get for
uninstalling things right underneath
nice oh okay well we'll come back to
that may be so but we do have WebGL
support coming so yeah there we go so
I'm not sure what happened there but
that's 50 K points per plot you know we
could sort of pan and zoom it's very
fast and so that's nice so a lot more
things coming there we're going to maybe
adding a few other 3d capabilities for
some schematic type 3d plots in the near
future but this is just the foundation
of that just enough to get rendering
integrated with our current system so
that's sort of where we are okay finally
one point oh so this year we really want
to make sure a big goal for us this year
is to have a one point 0 release and
what that means really to me is to have
a lot of stability right to have a lot
of guarantees about API stability and
protocol and interface stability so that
is where we're sort of at where we're
going guess I pause now and take maybe
just a few questions if there's any
questions before we really dive into the
notebooks and actually showing off
capability and having you guys do a
little bit of work yourself any
questions first yeah
so yeah so the question is whether Boca
jess is developed independently the
python bindings so they are absolutely
separate projects we do upload bouquet
js2 npm as its own package right now
they get released basically and sort of
lockstep with version numbers they don't
have to be in principle it's just easier
for us from a development perspective
because our team is kind of small but
you can absolutely use bouquet j/s as a
you know JavaScript library unto itself
I will say the you know the actual
functional sort of interface and
integrations with things like angular
reactor a little bit lacking right now
I'd love to actually help push that
forward I'm just not actually not we
need some people have some expertise
there to come help so if there are folks
that are interested in using bokja s and
helping push forward and really define
what those kind of interfaces should
look like I'd love to talk to you or
have you know come interact with us on
the the mailing lists are on the github
issues and push it forward but you can
certainly use it today as a library okay
other questions everyone ready to do
some coding see some examples okay well
let me give everyone a chance to bring
up the the slides so just as a reminder
this is on NB viewer and you should have
a series of notebooks let everyone go
ahead and download those nope I mean if
you're just going to watch and sort of
you know look at things you can look at
the notebooks on NB viewer but I
encourage everyone sorry I encourage
everyone to actually you know go and and
download the notebooks on and be viewer
again here so there's you can see
tutorial there's a couple we're going to
start with basic plotting talk a bit
about high-level charts maybe the little
models definitely styling so encourage
everyone sort of download those
notebooks from NB viewer does everyone
here know how to start the ipython
notebook by the way right so yeah so if
you have I Python installed ipython
notebook you can just you know what a
terminal PowerShell or bash prompt you
can just a i-5 own space notebook and
that will start a web servers to do that
in whatever directory has these these
notebook files and you'll get and you
should get a interface it looks
something like this yeah
sure I yeah so I so want to get masks
yes how many people want to use ipython
and follow the tutorial but don't have
it installed not that man ok so you're
all set ok yeah so but if you want to
there is a notebook service I just know
what it is that's why everybody said
there's a notebook service maybe show
could show us right quick but uh is on a
sure if that people could use yeah I can
show you a few LT there you go if you go
to studio as your FML net click on get
started either logging or do guest
access your launch into a GM else to do
you can skip the and one of the things
you'll see there is called a notebook
it's a preview service that we just
launched so yeah so basically you can
just pick a notebook and you'll end up
in a hosted Jupiter notebook that has
anaconda underneath of it and you can
use that to follow the tutorial if you
want all right yep great yeah let make
sure it's working yes it works excellent
great uh once makes your bouquets there
okay let's see what version okay well if
you do that though that maybe it's a
pretty old version of okay but we'll see
what happens we're the trial yeah okay
so yeah so if you go to in soap yes
they're great questions let's get
everyone set up so one you can go to NB
viewer there's also that's a great
question on github there is the actual
repository if you go to github okay
there is under the bouquet organization
there is this bouquet notebooks so I'll
leave that open as well so github.com /
bouquet / bouquet dash notebooks and
this has all of the notebooks any of the
supporting materials as well so you can
certainly clone that repository to get
the notebooks as well that's another way
to get the notebook so let me give
everyone just a few minutes you know
make sure that everyone that wants to
sort of follow along and actually run
exercises has a chance to get set up and
then I'm going to start going through
the notebooks and I'm going to do some
demonstrations so its a mix of
demonstrations and explanations as well
as some time for you guys to work on
things yourself if you'd like to
yeah so if you want to actually you know
work on this yourself and try some of
the exercises then you would want to
open up the notebook as a notebook in
you know the Jupiter ipython notebook
server real running on your local
machine yep yeah so these these are the
ones I mean this is the source code for
them you could clone this repository and
that would have the notebooks or you can
download them from envy viewers another
way if you go to if you go to NB viewer
if we go over here to indy view or
rather and i go to the introduction
notebook all these notebooks have a
little download button up at the top so
you can see here download notebook so
you could download it that way or you
can get them from github either ways
fine then once you have the notebooks
downloaded locally you can run ipython
notebook in the directory that those
files are in and then that will give you
at the ability to actually execute the
code and run things and try things out
for yourself okay
question yes so this is the first one
we're going to look at if you go to the
notebook viewer interface here it's
under tutorials it's this basic plotting
and it is 0-1 plotting I py & B or if
you're on github if you're on you know
bouquet notebooks it's under tutorial
here you can see all the different
notebooks here as well so it's the 01
plotting ipython notebook as well so ago
you can download that however you like
if you if you're familiar with get you
can clone the get repository if not the
easiest way is probably just through the
envy view or interface if you go there
there's this button up at the top where
you can download any of the notebooks
and that allow you to have the notebook
file locally and you can execute the
ipython notebook server to run the code
okay why don't I go ahead and get
started talking about things a little
bit and then as we break for the or not
break but as we pause for the first
exercise and give you know folks a
chance to work on things themselves if
we're still having problems and want to
run things and I can come along or Mike
and come around and we can try to help
get things sorted out okay so the first
thing I wanted to talk about is one of
the interfaces that bouquet provides so
bouquet has a very layered approach
towards its API there's a very low level
interface called bouquet top models and
this is really mirrors the JavaScript
library one to one and the idea is you
have a model in Python that represents
an axis or a guide of some sort or a
glyph or you know a plot with you know
all of these different attributes and
tools and so you have all these models
that represent these things and we can
turn those into these JavaScript
backbone models and so that's a very
one-to-one low-level sort of interface
and you just have to put things together
yourself and that's very flexible you
can do sort of whatever you want with
that interface but again it's kind of a
burden to have to know how to put all
these things together and so we have
some higher-level interfaces the
streamline that process and put things
together in sort of natural ways for you
to the first of those is this boat get
out plotting interface right and so I
would describe this starting from simple
default figures that have sort of
default tools default guides like axes
and grids we could add markers to these
glyphs and by glyphs I mean visual
things like lines or scatter points or
patches and so that's the idea is we
sort of get a basic plot with some basic
tools you know for free and we can sort
of throw data and glyphs at this and so
let's take a look at how we might do
that so the first thing is to do some
imports and if we actually want to go to
a live notebook here so we want to do
some import so here so from a bouquet de
io module I've imported this output
notebook function that's going to allow
me to see my my bouquet plots directly
in line in the ipython notebook if you
wanted to save to a file there's also an
output file function there's a show
function that allow us to see it there's
also now from this book a type plotting
interface there's really the central
thing that you have to import is this
thing called figure right so let's go
ahead and do that so that gets us the
things that we want to use we run output
notebook as well and we get a nice
getting nor the warning get a nice
message here that's
voce des was successfully loaded right
so the actual client library has been
loaded in and so we're ready to start
plotting so how do we actually do that
fairly straightforward you can do things
with just a little bit of code take a
look at a simple scatter plot first
right so I want to create a figure I
want to give it a size for the canvas
400 by 400 you could set that to be
whatever you want and then I want to
scatter some circles across so the one
of the simplest ways to do that is just
to put the data directly in line here
when I call circle and i can say i want
to plot you know these x coordinates
versus these y coordinates i want to
give it a size and pixels i can specify
things obviously like the line color the
fill colors you know the alpha all of
those things can be specified and so i
can execute that and then at the end i
say i want to show the results and sure
enough i get up my pot and because i've
used this bouquet top plotting interface
this plot again has a number of default
tools right so it has the pan tool
already built in it has you know a box
zoom tool that's ready to go has this
reset tool that resets the bounds or if
I XO you want to resize the plot I can
even drag and resize the plot wheel zoom
as well preview safe I can save a P&G so
again we're working on being able to do
sort of headless static image generation
right now you can at least get P and G's
out using this save tool so that's
available and yeah there we go so this
is you know that's okay so what let's
take a look and see if this matches up
with what we expect right so it's got
you know line color is navy the fill
color is orange the fill out for there
you can see the grid lines sort of
showing through it's definitely less
than one right so this allows us to
really have a chance to do this and so
we'll see a little bit later that you
know this is one way to spell things
where you put the data directly there
but you can also create these column
data sources as we call them and
reference different columns as the
values for X&Y and actually for almost
anything if you want to for instance
very the colors for every circle you can
definitely do that or the line style
that is a sort of vector I zabal over
your data so let's let's go ahead and
actually give everyone a quick chance to
take a look we'll take an exercise is to
basically do the same plot but try it
with the radius so instead of setting
size try setting a radius value and sort
of see what happens there radius values
by default or in sort of data units
right so size is pixels says how many
pixels I want the size to be but radius
is a data value measured in data space
and so let's take a few minutes maybe
just uh
three or four or five minutes and again
I'll take this opportunity to help
people that need need help getting set
up if they want to to work along but
otherwise give you a few minutes to try
that out and then we'll we'll talk about
it okay maybe a couple of quick words
about this actually i might go ahead and
take a step back and also just sort of
demonstrate downloading and running the
ipython notebook but let me go ahead and
just first sort of show this example so
here if I change this now to you know if
I just copy the poppy Facebook code and
I run with you know radius instead of
sighs well gosh it's you know it's so
zoomed out you can see it sort of the
radius takes these things in data units
so instead of specifying a number of
pixels you know I might want to pick it
like a radius of 1.5 or something and
they get smaller maybe point 15
obviously so it just depends so but if
you need to scale the size of you know
these these circles by the data you can
certainly do that and have them scale in
data space so the way that these behave
is obviously I know if i zoom in here
these circles get bigger because they're
specified in data units right I said I
want the radius to be you know from you
know 0.15 across and so that's that
actually is preserved as i zoom in but
these are specified in pixel units so
they don't get bigger or smaller as i
zoom in so that sort of just a
distinction between pixels screen space
units and and data unit so I just want
to draw that out what about other
markers besides circles obviously it's
possible to do that as well so it's very
simple in this case there's a dot square
method on figure so i can say p dot
square instead of peanut circle but here
another thing that's different is
instead of giving it a single size I've
given it now this vector of sizes right
and so now every single one of these
glyphs that get scattered has its own
size right so these sizes again are in
pixels or screen units but you can see
there's the small one and then they get
a little bit bigger all the way through
so it's possible to vectorize pretty
much any any one of the visual
properties of these glyphs you can
always sort of either give it a fixed
value or you can attach it to data and
we'll see how to do some of that later
yeah absolutely that's really what
that's really what radius the radius is
in data units right mm-hmm yes and you
want it to grow or shrink as you zoom in
or out yeah so that's what radius is
over me and radius obviously is so sighs
sort of measures the overall diameter
and radius is different but but they do
have these different units right by
default radiuses and data units and so
you could you could actually do it's a
little bit complicated but you could do
I think this would work sighs units I
don't use this much so let's try it okay
we may have gotten rid of that yeah we
can't do so sized units are always in
pixel units i used to be possible to
that but but the the radius though you
can definitely give it you know your
data and it will scale proportional to
the data size right and so in this case
you know I gave it a single radius but I
could certainly give it this list of
values for the radius right let's go
ahead and do that unless maybe make it
smaller because those will be really big
so Oh point ten three-point 30 and so
they're all scale but now as i zoom the
circles get bigger because they're the
radius is specified in data units right
is that does that answer the question
okay great okay so there are a lot of
markers that are built into bouquet a
standard sort of things you'd expect
right asterisks and circles with some
access through them or squares and
triangles and and all of these things so
all of those are sort of built into tip
okay so a quick exercise let folks do is
to just plot some different markers
right so try adapting the code that's
above and plotting some different
markers and the meantime I'm going to
show quickly just this workflow of maybe
getting the ipython notebooks erks i
think there are some folks who may not
have seen that so so yeah so just people
can start working or if you want to pay
attention to me I'll keep talking about
the ipython notebook download so to
download that I want to go to this
bouquet you know I started out at NB
viewer now I can see all my tutorial
notebooks I can go on to basic plotting
so again NB viewer is a static
presentation of ipython notebook so you
can't actually run code here
this isn't like the you know as your
notebook server that stroke was
mentioning or like a car or anything
like that you can't wrote and run any
code this is with a static you know
snapshot of a notebook but we can still
download them locally and run them
locally and so that's what this button
here is so I'm going to say click on
that i'm going to say save link as and
i'm going to save it in my home
directory or my desktop rather as this
01 plotting and so now if i go to a
terminal and i go you know to the
directory where those notebooks are and
i type ipython space notebook and so you
can do that in powershell or in you know
bash shell or whatever is appropriate
that brings up this server and i can see
oh there's the notebook i downloaded so
sorry i should have gone over that first
that's probably a good thing to do at
the start of the tutorial so i'll do
that next time so but here you can see
that and now if I click on this notebook
here this isn't a static presentation or
static image I can actually run and
execute the cells and I do that by
hitting the shift enter key so I can
execute this import by saying shift
enter I can you know execute this cell
by saying shift enter and then I hit
shift in turn on this zone so that
actually execute sand runs this Python
code in the in the notebook server and I
can see the output directly in line in
the notebook so hopefully that sorry I
apologize for not maybe showing that
more explicitly in the beginning that's
a good thing to do and I will do that in
the future so question so if it's not
working for you I'd love to see it let's
make an issue it's definitely has always
liked here if I go to the resize button
I definitely can resize this plot so if
you're having an issue I would love to
take a look at it maybe a little bit
later on and we can maybe finally get
how to issue and see what's different
about your configuration or what might
be broken okay question
so that's a good question you know it's
interesting there's a Cajun alee some
subtleties actually around that
especially with some of the markers like
circle where there's actually ostensibly
a radial symmetry right but if you don't
have a one to one aspect ratio sometimes
people get exposed or at least
unexpected to them you know
mathematically speaking if you have non
one to one aspect ratio and you're
plotting circles you probably ought to
try to squish them or something but a
lot of times people don't want that and
so you can definitely have there's not
really any way to have I think mixed
units if what you're asking for we sort
of tried that before although with some
of the other glyphs that we're going to
see like rectangles you can for instance
have like a hide in screen units and a
width in data units and so we'll see
some examples of that but for the
markers the oval to it I believe we can
check it when we get to that little bit
later well oval actually oval is a
couple of Bezier curves joint it's not
it's not on the lips we probably ought
to add us actual lips but but yeah so
oval though you have to specify the
major in the minor axis separately and
so that for that reason you can say oh I
want you to measure in this dimension I
want you to measure in screen mentions
in this mission I want you to measure in
data dimensions circles though don't
have that even though they're actually
do have this extent in two dimensions
you only give it one parameter and that
that does complicate things a little bit
if you don't have a one to one aspect
ratio so but that's that's any question
we can talk about that sort of more
awful I come come find me we'll talk
about now shows an example it'll be good
okay so let's see so the next exercise
here was just to show some different
different kinds of markers here so again
I can just copy you know the code up
here and sort of substitute in different
different ones and we can see the
results it's fairly straightforward you
know here instead of squares i want to
add you know triangle and sure enough i
get triangles hopefully no surprise
there or i can add you know x sorry it's
a lowercase X gives me little x markers
around so you know it's fairly
straightforward I mean it's you know you
need to be able to plot simple things
and simple scatters and bow cake and let
you do that okay so scatters are great
what about lines we want to build the
plot obviously data that has maybe some
connected
no component to it maybe as a time
series we want to show or whatever we
want to have these sort of continuous
lines we can do that very easily in the
book cadet plotting interface there's a
line method on figure Pete outline it's
very similar it takes the same kind of
arguments you can give it the data as
we'll see you later you can also give it
a reference to data in more these column
data sources but here you can specify
things like the line width or the line
alpha or whatever you want and you can
get that line and again because it's
polka dot plotting it just comes with
all the tools sort of built-in and this
basic sort of standard functionality
another example here let's take a look
at images it's definitely possible to
show images this one's a little bit more
sophisticated I'm actually using numpy
here to curate the color data there's a
couple of different ways to show images
in boquete one is that you can create an
array of data like maybe you have
temperature values or pressure values or
whatever and you can send the data and
then you can tell bouquet to color map
it on the client with some particular
color map but you can also send actual
just raw rgba data so that's what's
going on here is I'm actually using
numpy to create this rgba data and then
I'm calling my image RGB a renderer just
like i did with circle or triangle or
line and sure enough that's going to
give me a plot that has this data so i
just did a little simple diagonal sort
of gradient across and and varied the
color you know very the RGB values but
you can see again it just lets us show
it up so whether you have raw rgba data
maybe you have data coming off a you
know if your if your scientists you
might have data coming off some sensor
or a camera ccd or something like that
or maybe you have a raise of data there
are actual values either way whether
it's raw rgba data or values that you
want to color map on the client voce can
do both of those a lot of other kind of
glyphs not going to go into a deep dive
about this is a lot of material we want
to cover but at least mention what's
available maybe click on the links and
show you in the user's guide what's
there obviously rectangles and ovals
things like that these things have a
width and height these have an extent
they're not scatter markers but they are
positioned by their centers segments and
raise all kinds of wedges and arcs and
annular wedges things like that as well
as specialized curves if you want to be
able to draw things like bezzie a
quadratic or cubic curves you can do
that as well but for instance if I go
two rectangles and ovals here
and we look at some of those you know
just a fairly straightforward stuff
again we can vary the parameters of
these either we can pass fixed values or
we can you know pass connected to the
data in this case you know there's quads
is what this one is so quad is a axis
aligned bounding box rectangles you can
also specify an angle for so those can
be rotated so here in this case we've
actually rotated those angles and of
course the angle can be vectorized over
data as well and ovals are very similar
again they take sort of a width and a
height center position and an angle and
you can sort of move those around all of
these by the way or so this is the
user's guide all of these are in this
user's guide for booking applauding all
the glyphs have live plots with examples
so you can go play around with them and
sort of see exactly what the code look
like to get you started very quickly and
very easily okay go back here okay so
that's great we can you can cross some
circles on a pot or whatever what do we
want to draw multiple things on on a
single plot right I mean that's a pretty
common thing you probably want to be
able to do so that's fairly
straightforward in boquete you just
simply keep calling more more glyph
functions right so I can call you know p
dot line and p dot circle on the same
figure in sure enough if you look at the
results well that's great we get a line
that has these nice markers on it so
higher level interfaces might do this
automatically for us so this polka dot
plotting interface is kind of in the
middle it's kind of a layer level of
verbosity similar to MATLAB if you're
familiar with a doormat plot lib and so
it sort of lets you specify what these
visual shapes should look like without
imbuing a lot of semantic meaning or
sort of data transformation so we're
working on a bouquet that charts layer
that's even higher level that sort of
takes care of some of those things but
anyway this is basic plotting so let's
give everyone a few moments to maybe do
this exercise and maybe the last
exercise so the last exercise is just to
try to use some of the different glyphs
like rectangle or oval yourself and this
last next exercise here is simply too
you know combine a few glyphs together
on your own plot so we'll get everyone
for five minutes and again if you have
questions I can come take take a look or
wave mic over and then we'll we'll be
done with this section we'll move on to
the next chapter will get that chart
the next section I want to go through
just run through very quickly is this
bouquet tat charts high-level charting
interface notebook so I'm just going to
run through this as examples and talk
about a little bit we won't stop to
pause and the exercise because I want to
get to the styling and adding
interactions notebooks and maybe the
embedding one as well but the idea again
is that you have sort of very layered
levels of interfaces so Bo cadet charts
you know maybe does some work for you
right the idea is that you can have sort
of one-liners to create all kinds of
different common charts and maybe those
charts even involve doing some kind of
statistical aggregation or you know in
the case of histogram or a box plot and
so that sort of all wrapped up in the
chart definition so again here i'm using
numpy and pandas pandas if you don't
know is a really fantastic library
that's really helped spur the adoption
of Python for data science it's a sort
of a tabular sort of excel in a library
kind of a you know that kind of notion
of like a labeled columns but you know
being able to manipulate them
programmatically that's what pan this is
all about it's been really useful in a
lot of context we do i'll put notebook
again to load bouquet into the notebook
and the first chart here is a simple
scatter chart you notice you know I gave
it my values there's a variety of ways
that I can give it the values and you
know basically going to auto color right
so it sort of auto breaks down the
groups and colors those for us again we
have sort of a default set of two of
tools here in this case we also have
this nice crosshair tool I should
mention that we're currently working on
this is the newest and sort of most
recent interface and we're still
evaluating and evolving this interface a
little bit so I did want to mention that
the book it up cloudy interface is very
stable Bo cadet models is basically
completely stable but there will be some
upcoming changes to bouquet charts to
make it a little bit easier to use with
things like data frames here's another
example with stack bars so again a lot
of different ways to specify sort of
this metals data here I put it in a data
frame with you know bronze silver and
gold columns and I can get a nice stack
bars out of that as well finally here's
a histogram to actually get populations
different histograms right so I get
create a two different populations here
there's a normal distribution as well as
a log normal distribution in my pandas
dataframe and I can call the histogram
pond so I can actually get you know I
can tell the number of bins and I want
it actually does the you know uses numpy
to create that or to calculate that
histogram and overly those two
population
one another and give you a nice legend
there as well so the idea behind charts
is really to be able to generate a high
level charts very quickly and then the
the further work that we're sort of
about to embark on is to be able to
combine different charts but also to
have things like faceting throwing into
that as well so instead of just
necessarily stacking or grouping you
might say hey I want to facet by this
other variable and then group or stack
by a different one so that's you know
this is what's there now it's evolving a
little bit there's going to be quite a
few exciting things I think in the next
few months coming into a book at that
charge I just wanted to have at least a
quick chance to show that off oh yeah
good question so I mentioned in the
initial slides that we had added some
validation code we haven't actually
turned on the throwing exceptions if
there's errors but it this has actually
been very instructive for us we've seen
that some in some cases we're actually
doing some things we shouldn't do so one
of the one of the sort of assumptions
about these column data source
structures that I haven't talked a lot
about yet but there's underlie all the
plots is that there are collection of
columns that all sort of have the same
length there's sort of a cheap pandas
dataframe if you will and in this case
we've currently constructed one that has
columns that aren't all the same length
and we shouldn't be doing that so it
doesn't in this case cause the the plot
from rendering and it's again we haven't
turned off sort of the strict checking
so that would actually raise an
exception but in the near future
probably in boquete zero point ten these
kind of validation errors you know we
check right before we actually generate
the jason and try to display the plot if
there's a validation error with lexie
raise an exception we haven't turned
that on just yet yeah question we have
tool tip support we have quite a lot of
tooltip support let me let me go first
of all I should mention anyway bouquet
top idea to org if you go to there as
well this is the main dock side has that
users guide it has a quick start there's
also this reference guide I mention but
there's also a gallery you know there's
a lot different ways to learn people
learn in different ways one of the best
ways that I learned is to just go say
hey what you know what looks like what I
want I'm going to go look at that coat
and try to bang it into shape until it
does you know exactly what I want but if
you go to some of these examples for
instance this is a reproduction of a New
York Times chart about us unemployment
this has a tooltip hovering over right
and so you can see there's a hover tool
here it's very easy to spell the hover
tool here you just say i want the label
to be date and
eight and i want to show you know here's
the date and the the rate columns or
what i want to show up so that's one
example with the hover tip and we'll
actually get some more of this later but
here's another example at this periodic
table chart or we show sort a lot more
information in the hover tooltip so
that's in this adding interactions
notebook that's coming up in just a bit
so but thank you for asking if the
question was about I think that's what
you're asking about yeah great what do
you mean by bind it to a map ha so I
mean the short answer is no so bouquet
doesn't use matplotlib to implement
anything right so we do have it yeah we
do have an impie l2 bouquet and it
offers some limited support for
converting matplotlib to tube okay and
so depending on the plot you're trying
to show it may work yes we use a library
called MPL exporter which is quite nice
but it doesn't necessarily cover the
full range of what map all it does
there's currently in the works a the
matplotlib team is working on a new
feature to be able to have basically a
Jason export you know save and load
capability and once they've got that we
can make basically any kind of
interruption interoperability happen but
that's a little ways off but right now
you can get some basic interoperability
with MPL tube okay and I can't guarantee
that will work in every circumstance
because there's some impale plots are
just sort of too sophisticated for for
us to handle through that interface but
more will be available later cool cool
good questions okay well let's get back
to let's go through this styling
document so this is 0 for if you're
looking on the ipython notebook NBD
viewer site I waited basic plotting I
sort of went over very quickly
high-level charts I'm going to skip
low-level models I don't think that it
wouldn't take too much time to do that
but I encourage everyone to look at it
if you if you actually just run it i'll
show you what's in it the low level
models interface definitely gives you
the most flexibility but again it's sort
of you know the responsibility is sort
of upon you to put everything together
in the right way you can think of it
sort of as a bunch of sort of you know
building blocks and you know how do we
actually sort of put those together and
so
showing me I'm not sure what's going on
there let me restart this and put there
we go so this is another reproduction
one of our developers just recently did
I'm not sure what that look up was but
this is a reproduction of sort of
showing uh usain bolt's sort of Olympic
you know compared to other Olympic
sprinters and you know sort of how far
behind you know other people were and
sort of you know what year they they ran
and so you know it's just the example of
having sort of a lot of flexibility sort
of place things in different locations
and have a lot of control over the style
like here's this little extra annotation
and that sort of thing so you know you
can definitely put this stuff together
with a low level models but I think
right now maybe this styling is a little
bit more appropriate useful for this
interface so let's take a look so again
I'm an import you know for the notebook
and just to mention a lot of this
information is in the ipod and the users
guide right so we can see a list of all
the different properties that we can
sell we can set of this all the
different plots here that we can you
know the attributes that we can set on
plots and so if we click on these you
know and we look in the users guide you
know we can see here's all the different
visual properties things like you know
the fill properties line properties text
properties right other things you might
normally imagine and then we can set
plot properties as well things like here
you know they did watch the dimensions
of the plot the title obviously the
background so all this stuff is here
with live plots you can sort of see
examples of how to set those so let's go
through a few here actually maybe let's
take a look at yeah I will just go ahead
and copy this one so i just copied one
from down below it's a simple little
plot but you know i can i can say things
like oh I want my plot heights or plot
with rather to be 600 instead and I can
get a bigger plot I can set things like
a title you know equals my title and get
that to show up so that's the sort of
the plot property so that's take a few
minutes and let you guys just sort of
look at the different plot properties
again I encourage you to follow the link
here
for properties but also to this plots
link under styling visual attributes
that shows you know I can set the
different border shapes around the the
plot the different sort of outlines
around it so you guys can sort of play
around with the visual appearance of you
know one of the plots you created in the
last exercise or a new one that you want
to create and i'll give you just a
couple of minutes to take a look at that
and then we will move on if you have
questions will come take a look
say as I go through this I'll mentioned
that there is another way to set things
right so here I've sort of passed
arguments to figure here but it's also
possible to say things like you know to
set these as attributes and actually yep
oh oh yeah sorry I yeah i will update
that later sorry i did make those
changes to their so i need to push those
still I will make changes and they'll be
there so if you just go to the users
guide you go to styling visual
attributes that's that's coming over
that's film and this actually just
reminded me I was the question the back
of the class from someone was about sort
of you know intellisense and does it
complete and I was sort of blanking I'd
forgotten that it's not actually the
function arguments where you can get
that sort of completion but if you start
something like this where you say p dot
whatever you can get a list now of all
the attributes so here like outline line
dash outline line alpha i can set all
these things you know so there's all
these different outline properties i can
set so if i want to set out line line
you know dash equals to you know 3 comma
3 and i can get this nice weird dashed
outline if that's what I wanted but
there's all kinds of things here you
know I can set the if I just hit p p dot
i'll get a list of a bunch of stuff but
you can see the things like the you know
the the functions for the glyph
functions but also things like min
border and the outline properties and
things like the title and all of this
thing so sorry i had a little bit of a
brain freeze there but uh yeah so that's
a little bit harder that's a good
suggestion I don't think we're quite I
don't think we're quite there I won't
say that it's impossible you'd have to
get ahold you have to make the circle if
and then get a hold of it and so what we
have now is a tab completion for
properties and so if you have a hold of
one of these circle glyphs you could do
that but getting a hold of that I'm
going to say is a little bit to the
maybe a task right now so that's a good
suggestion I think we should figure out
to make that happen I'm not sure if I
Python notebook offers that kind of
integration but we could also look at
other IDEs as well that might support
that kind of intellisense and if there's
anything we can do to make those kind of
integrations happen I would certainly
to shift tab well oh so that brings up
the doc string which is definitely
useful here but I don't know that that's
going to get us everything because
there's a lot of we have a lot of sort
of magic magic wait you know the the
bouquet system uses some fairly
sophisticated means to be able to auto
serialize these models into Jason and so
in some cases it's sort of short
circuits some of the standard Python
which not short circuits but helps
automate i should say some of that
machinery and so we just need to help it
along to make to provide more help so
cool okay so that's an example of making
a plot let's take a look at axes
obviously probably you mean you want to
manipulate and change the visual
appearances of things like axes and
grids so let's take a look at how you
might do that as well so the plot itself
the figure here has this attribute like
x-axis or y-axis or taxes and these
actually return lists because you might
have more than one x x axis it's
actually possible to have like twin
access plots where you have you know
different axes on different scales so
you actually get back a list but this
list is actually a bit special you can
set attributes on it and it will set the
attribute on all the value you know all
the objects in that list right so here
in this case I just have one access if I
set you know p x axis axis label the
temperature that's going to have the
effect that I want and so it's just a
nice sort of convenience and so we can
take a look at some of those here so a
lot of different things you can set
about the axis right so you can set the
actual line properties of the you know
the line itself you can set the text
properties of the label and also how far
it sort of stands off in the access you
can set the the major labels or the you
know what labels the tix the major tix
you can set you know the line or the
text properties of that as well as you
know what the angle the orientation it's
at the major ticks and the Minor tix you
can you can set all kinds of properties
about you know what do those look like
as well and so here's kind of an example
of showing some of those here where you
know I've done pi over four but I could
do you know pi over 6 and rotate those
labels right and so now those are
labeled or I can do something like
TDOT not x-axis dot liner tick in this
is how many pixels it sort of extends
into the plot I can set it to be
negative 10 or 20 to and so it just
changes the visual appearance is
probably kind of hard to see on that
scale that I'm changing the how how far
the tix extend inside the plot so you
can have really fine grain control over
a lot to the visual properties you don't
always have to and we try to pick
sensible defaults and again we're
working to you know make a visual design
pass to make a things look even better
by default and we're also looking at
adding sort of templating and being able
to have lots of different you know
template styles that are easily
selectable into usable between but at
the lowest level you can always get down
to all of these you know sort of knobs
and dials and really customize the
visual appearance of these plots okay
this one example shows sort of a lot of
things here change you know I've changed
the the color of one of the axes and
I've changed the color of the tick
labels and their orientation and let's
go up to the code yeah so here you know
I've given given labels to the axes I've
changed their standoffs all kinds of
things so again you have lots of control
over the visual aspects so maybe take a
few minutes and if you guys everyone
here just wants to you know show up lot
and maybe play around with some of these
properties again you can start by just
sort of copying and pasting and seeing
how things go and then modifying things
to try to see how they look but if you
all want to do that will take maybe just
three or four minutes and then we'll
finish up which one is remind me what
all that does oh no there's not but
that's like that's a great idea so those
kind of suggestions are great to get
from you know from users so I'd love to
get that is like a feature request on on
on the github we definitely want to be
able to have the ability to define
user-defined styles but also to have
multiple sets of you know sort of common
styles that we can switch between and so
sort of a d spine style exactly themes
exactly right so
yeah so in fact I'd be gray like having
a seaborne theme and so that's that's I
think if thing will have probably in
your future but yeah question tonight oh
yeah well so I think I will have to look
into that mr you mean this specifically
the one the mun dimensional zoom here oh
you want that you want to be able to say
i want it yes you can yes so there is
you can turn off on this the zoom tool
there's a field that says I want it to
only zoom in this dimension or only zoom
in that dimension yeah yeah so we
haven't talked too much about how to add
tools there's adding interactions we'll
talk a little bit more about that but
you can actually add the tool object
yourself and configure it the way you
want or you can pull out the tool object
and configure it the way you want but
that's a that's a configuration on the
tool no but you will be able to soon
this is an old long-standing issue that
probably should have been implemented a
while ago and it's been asked for a few
times in the last week so i think i'm
just going to go ahead and I'm going to
do it like you know this weekend
sometime or do my best to so it
shouldn't be hard to implement so we
just need to do it yeah great good
questions question was whether or not
you can have a max maximum or minimum
bounds on the range and the answer is
hopefully very soon yeah question yeah
oh sorry I didn't eyes or two questions
are yes oh so if you use output file one
quick way is to use output file instead
of outputs show that'll just generate
basically a plot with nothing else
inside of a HTML file and then it'll
open up a browser when you could when
you type show or a new execute show the
other notebook that were going to see in
a bit the embedding one actually shows a
variety of ways like if you want to
embed a chart in your own custom HTML or
serve it up from a flat server that's
what that embedding I think we're gonna
have time to get to that one but that's
what that shows as well but if you just
do output file and then do show it will
save it to an HTML file a fairly
standard one and then just open a
brother okay I think your head of course
as well yeah yeah so if you go to the
user's guide it's good question was
about log scales Swiss course was first
question was about showing two browser
instead of in the notebook which you can
use output file for and then the next
question was about log scales for the
book about plotting interface if you go
down to specifying access types you can
see here there's ways to specify
categorical axes datetime axes right
that zoom in now to nice you know nice
sort of numbers when you zoom in and out
but also log scale axes here as well so
here's an example that shows a log scale
so this is an example we're having sort
of that math tech capability to be
really nice if you nice to have much
nicer annotations here that showed the
exponents as exponent we're not quite
there yet so so it has this hokey you
know carrot for the exponent but like i
said i think we've identified the
technology in a way forward so we can
hopefully integrate that contact package
to get sort of math text annotations
very soon and then you have much nicer
labels for particularly yeah other
questions yeah one more question yeah
yeah I'll let me together sure let's uh
so we're this is a pretty basic tutorial
I'm probably not gonna get to a lot of
that may be a little bit in the adding
interactions section in just a bit but
definitely come talking I'm going to be
here all weekend and also for the Sprint
on monday so i always have an answer
anyone's questions and we can sit down
and even try to bang out some code here
and there so just come find me but let's
wait for the adding interactions
sections as you see what we get to today
in the tutorial okay moving along
because we're running long so also
another thing we can configure is grids
of course let's just see some examples
maybe and we won't maybe pause for an
exercise but we'll just talk about it so
here again so just like x-axis and
y-axis and access I can have an X period
why grid and grid sort of convenience
functions on figures that gives me back
all of the you know the X grids are all
the Y grids and so i can set properties
on those like hey i want to set the
alpha for you know the why grid to this
and i want to set the line dashing for
the Y grid for that and I want to turn
off the X grid completely and so now you
can have this nice plot that only has
two you know the horizontal rules for
the grids another thing we can do is
fill bands right so that's pretty easy
there's a grid band fill color option
that you can give it and here i said
navy and i gave it an alpha and so i
have a nice for these nights filled
bands in between so all those are again
just analogous to that axis these
actually return lists so if i look at
pdx grid i actually get a this this
thing that looks a lot like a list
it's actually a subclass of list that
lets me set attributes sort of on all
the items at one time and so that's what
X grid is going to give you okay last
section here on styling it's also
possible to style legends somewhat as
well just like with x squared Y grid x
axis y axis all those there is a peel
edge and this is you know an attribute
of figures basically gives you back my
legend object and so I can set things
like the orientation I want it to be the
bottom left and right now it's pretty
basic we're going to add some more
functionality to being able to position
the legend right now you can basically
give it one of the corners or a standoff
but we're going to make that a bit more
sophisticated as well but right now you
basically in each of these glyph
functions you say where is it you know
legend equals three times sine X and for
everyone that you do that it collects
those together and draws the legend for
all those things together so you can see
here that three times sigh neck is the
green squares with line and two sine X
is the you know the dotted orange line
and just sine of X is the blue solid
squares with line and that's because I
passed in legend as the argument to all
the glyph functions and they basically
just collects up all the legends that
are the same and draws those cliffs
together okay let's go ahead and move on
to sharing right so this actually is
going to answer some of the questions
they're over here about ways to share
bouquet plot so let's take a look at
that okay so here I'm again going to use
pandas that I'm actually reading from
the Yahoo Finance API as I charge a
yahoo or something like that it so it's
a you know it gives reading this
financial data and so I can read that
into a panda's data frame and so here I
have a you know pandas dataframe for
Apple Microsoft and IBM and all the
things and and so here I can plot lines
for that and so this function this is
actually a function nivin show my paw
but this is actually this make figure
function and I tell it things like I
want a date time and i want to show you
know the date versus the adjusted
closing price i can set the colors and i
can set things like you know the all the
all the things we styled in the last
section i can set all those things there
and that gives me this nice plot
and so you know in the notebook as we've
seen we do our imports we run output
notebook to load the notebook Boca jes
in the notebook and then I can just you
know get my plot and call show and did I
call output file there somewhere I must
have run output file interesting I'm
sure where I did let me actually restart
this kernel clear all the output that
was weird okay so yeah so pull in the
data takes a second to actually read
that down I'll put notebook and there we
go so I must have a think I must have
written up with file somewhere we'll see
how I put file in just a second so here
we go so yeah so here's my plot I've got
my nice daytime accessed at scales
another thing you can see here is the
son of you turn off but one of the
things that we have that can help
preserve interactive response rates when
you have a lot of data points and using
the canvas is something called level of
detail down sampling and so this is you
can turn this off you can customize it
but by default if there's a certain
number of points it actually just starts
decimating the data during interactive
motions like pans and drag so you can
maintain these nice high interactive
rates for panning and zooming actually
with the WebGL capability we added this
may become less and less important but
certainly if you if you want to use or
need to use just the standard canvas
back in then that log down sampling can
be helpful and that's also describing
the users guide as well ok so the next
thing we can do is we can say output
file in size now I say output file
tutorial sharing at HTML and now if I
call show this is what it does it opens
up this file just a very basic HTML file
it just has you know the the plot in it
and nothing else so no sort of extra
styling or formatting but it's the same
plot you know it's got the same tools I
can resize it you know I can pan my pan
to like an panika hand it around and I
can use my wheel zoom and this is this
is the way this is created is this is a
static HTML file with the data embedded
in it I can actually just email this
some of there's no extra of you know
server anything required it's just a
static document even though it has these
interactive tools in it and we'll see in
just a bit in the next section you can
actually have a lot of rich
interactivity in these static documents
okay so yep
so yeah so that's that that's that point
that I mentioned where the static output
was something we're working on that's
actually surprisingly thorny technical
issue and right now you can use the with
user interaction you can hit this save
tool and you can get a PNG but that
requires user interaction so to be able
to do it like headless lee without user
interaction is something we're still
working on that is I would say current
fairly high priority for us can't give
you a firm estimate but it certainly
would be in a 1 point 0 release of food
later this year there's a few approaches
we're going to try to making that happen
so yeah question I'm not sure in the
note so the notebook it should never be
a problem at tie the notebook
occasionally the notebook with it's out
of order execution and also the
publication of javascript and mechanism
is a little bit complicated occasionally
it can get a hiccup I just typically
restart the notebook and clear the
output but obviously if there's a way we
can reproduce some problem i love this
to find a way to fix it it's just
sometimes it's sometimes it's hard to
reproduce these little pickups in the
notebook but most of that's just because
bouquets a fairly it's a fairly
complicated in large library and so
sometimes there's a little bit a little
bit of it interacts with a notebook
that's a little weird we actually used
to have a very sort of more matlab file
interface that was implicit there was
sort of an implicit figure and you would
just say circle or square and we found
is that sort of having that with the
possibility of executing things out of
order the notebook really just became
impossible to sort of reason about
things and so that's why now we have
like a p dot circle you know plot dog
circle their plot line and it's a little
bit more explicit but there's still
cases where it's occasionally strange
anyway okay next thing show how we can
template book a plot into your own your
own sort of you know custom document
right so here this is a jinja to
template so jinja to is just a
templating language it's very commonly
used in sort of python web app dev here
you can see that I've referenced you
know from the CDN the bouquet in this
case 090 release but I've got a you know
a title there and here's a paragraph and
then I put in the script and div and
that's so are actually the plot and the
the script are going to go so here's my
template so i can define this jinja to
template and then there's this bouquet
embed components function
and so if I pass that too if I pass my
plot to that components function what
that's going to give me back is a script
and a div and so those are exactly the
things that I need to substitute into my
plot and wherever the div goes that's
going to be replaced with the plot right
basically how it works very simple so
here I can for instance call the HTML
this is ipython publication method HTML
and I can just render the template and
sure enough it shows up there but now it
has this extra formatting right it has
you know hello bouquet and below is the
simple plot so you could imagine serving
this up on a web server you know that
template so you can embed bouquet plots
in your own documents very easily I
think there was actually recently a pull
request from a new outside contributor
who added the ability to also specify
your own custom template to 22 out not
output file but bookie dot save so you
can also do this sort of in a more
simple way p.m. so if you could imagine
if you have lots of CSS and you know
want to be able to sort of control the
way things look this is a hopefully a
nice way to do that just finally as an
example we can actually use flask right
here to do that right so here very
simple class server the way flask works
is you define a function and you have it
return some HTML and then you you add
this little decorator that says whenever
someone hits the route you know route or
whatever whatever endpoint you want to
define call this function to get the you
know the result and so if i run this if
I make a flask app and I say app dot
route and I give a function that simply
returns my plot rendered from that
template I can go here and let's
uncomment this I say app run and so
let's actually go to local host port 50
50
and we see if there's been served up by
our flasks server right so very easy
lots of different ways to embed bouquet
plots into X a flask or Django or IAS or
whatever whatever web framework you're
using is super simple polka dot
components is a really great way to do
that there's also something called
autoload static if you want to be able
to save the data sort of in a sidecar
j/s file or the script you can use auto
load static autoload server if you're
using the bouquet server we're on I
talked about about the server today I
just mentioned again we're sort of
working on making the server better and
simpler and easier for people to deploy
so but that's there as well so lots of
different ways to embed bouquet
visualizations in your in your plots
okay great too many tabs there we go
stop the colonel okay so questions about
this this section for sharing and
embedding actually do want to show one
quick thing is you know bouquet also has
its own sort of notion of like a widget
set and so when I stalk about embedding
I don't just mean plots I could mean
multiple plots but I could also mean you
know here's a couple of plots arrayed in
different ways but I can also embed
different kinds of widgets like buttons
and button groups and things like that
as well so those are also possible to
embed and define events that happened
when they when they get to interact with
of course okay speaking of which let's
talk about adding interactions right so
the first thing to talk about for adding
interactions is you know how do we get
some simple layouts so we're going to be
we have some simple stuff built in the
bouquet things like an ocean of like a
grid plot or an H box or v box but of
course you can always embed individual
plots you know into your own layout or
your own templates however you want
right so if you don't want them in our
simple layout you can just embed them in
your own custom templates but for the
purposes of this tutorial I'm just going
to show for instance this grid plot so
here I've arranged three plots in a row
and you can see they know they all sort
of have the same set of tools defined
and and that's really great
and the reason it's nice to show that is
what I actually want to get to some of
the cooler stuff is it's possibly have
linked interactions like linked
interaction or linked panning and Link
rushing very simply in bocage so when I
say link spanning what I mean is if I
pan or zoom one of the plots if I change
the range of one of the thoughts that
some other plots should be able to
respond automatically and do the same
thing and when I say link brushing what
I mean is that if I make a selection on
one plot that really I should be able to
get the same selection highlight the
same corresponding points on a different
point so here's an example of using linq
planning so to get linked panning in
boquete it's very simple all you do is
you share a range object between two
plots so here I've created three
different plots s1 s2 s3 so I've got
three calls to figure you know the first
one I'm drawing circles on and the next
i'm drawing triangles and then squares
but what i've done is i've pulled off
this thing called s1 why range and s 1 X
range and I passed those as parameters
to the other pot so I've shared both the
x and y range for the second plot and
I've shared only the X range on the
third plot so what that means is that if
I pan any of these plots the other ones
responding kind so because the second
plot shares both ranges they're linked
in both dimensions but because that
third plot only shares the X range it
only moves correspondingly and in in the
X dimension right so it's very easy
sharing you know sharing ranges is how
you get linked panning in Boca so for
that's the easy succinct way of
expressing that so let's go ahead and
take a yeah well actually let me show
you the next section then we'll take a
break for an exercise so links brushing
is also typically easy to express in the
case where you have the same kind of
data source share between two plots so
here I want to introduce something we
haven't sort of seen before it's I
mentioned it this column data source and
the column data source is really kind of
like a panda stata frame it's just a
bunch of named column so there's you
know the name of the column is X and y0
and y1 and it just has a array or an
umpire array or a list of data for each
of those names and so here I've created
literally a Python list in this case but
they could be numpy arrays or whatever
you want and here I create this values
y0 and y1 with some list comprehensions
and i pass i put those in a dictionary
pass them to my column data source
to get linked to get linked like
brushing all I have to do is share now a
data source so I when I call left circle
I tell it explicitly I want to pass in
this data source that's where the data
should be found from and same thing for
my circle and now notice instead of
actually passing in the the literal data
lists as the arguments I passion the
name of the column I want to take the X
values from the X column in my data
source and I want to take the the Y
values from the y0 case and then in the
Y one column from my data source and so
now we can see that we get two plots
where the first plot has you know X
versus Y one and the second one has X
versus Y 2 and so that's absolute value
of x here and x squared here and so we
can see that's exactly what these two
plots are but more importantly if I make
a selection on one that selection is
automatically mirrored in the other
right so we can get this kind of linked
behavior very simply and sometimes it
needs to be a little bit more
sophisticated when you know if you have
data that doesn't sort of match up one
to one then we'll we'll talk about that
in a second but in the simple case where
you have you know one set of columns
that you want to generate multiple plots
from you can simply share that data
source between the plots and you can get
these nice linked brushing basically for
no no cost so okay so let's take let's
take a quick few minutes here that
people work on whatever these exercises
sort of you find most interesting or
most useful again I can come around and
take a look Mike's here you can come
around and take a look if you have
questions just raise your hand will take
maybe five minutes or so and let you
guys let everyone here play around and
then and then we'll finish up with some
more different interactions yeah if I
get just to get everyone's attention
back we are getting close to the end of
our two hours with a few more
interesting examples I wanted to show
off and maybe we can do some exercises
on though as well as well just depending
so hover tools actually I'm a little bit
remiss I haven't actually added a hover
tool example here in the notebook so let
me go to the gallery where there are
some notebooks that I can show you here
here for instance is this periodic table
again I have a note hover tool and I can
drill down into all the additional
columns of data that
no I'm not necessarily showing visually
in some way but I can show them in my
hover tool another example with the
hover tool is I think this one may be no
doesn't have a hover tool Texas yeah oh
yeah there's a good one right so if we
go to the Texas example it's Texas
unemployment and so I have this hover
tool it just shows me you know what is
the name of the county what is
unemployment rate what is the lat lon
right now I have it so that you know it
the hover tool follows the mouse exactly
you can actually have it snapped to the
sort of the center of the glyph even for
patches it'll actually compute the
centroid and so to snap to those very
nicely and down here at the bottom again
you can just sort of see it's really
easy to configure this you don't even
need to use the default vixen air
anymore you can just give it a tuple I
want you know name and the name column
and then I want unemployment rate in the
and the rate column and percentage lat
lon there's just this simple syntax
that's described in the docks so really
you can add hover tools there's another
one it's also possible to customize if I
go to the users guide and we go to I
think styling visual attributes might
actually be under adding interactions
now I think about it brushing max for
hover okay it's not where I thought it
was whoa ok well I'm not I'm actually
not sure is it's possible to customize
the appearance of the Oliver tool right
so that's sort of a default you know
hover tool but you can give it your own
your own sort of HTML a little template
to show up in that that hover gives so I
don't have an example to show handy but
I'll at least mention that that's
possible there is an example in the
examples directory in github that shows
that it shows that okay so continuing on
under interactions another thing to
mention is ipython interactors right so
I showed that we sort of have our own
set of bouquet default widgets that you
can use but there's also this great set
of widgets that come with the ipython
notebook they're called interactors and
it's really nice so you can actually
hook those up to tube-ok plots very
fairly easily so here I'm you know
defined a plot it's a figure it's got a
line I'm passing in my column data
source explicitly it's got
columns for x and y and what does and
then i define this function update and
what does that do well it gets the
parameters for the frequency and the
amplitude and the and the function and
the in the phase and it basically just
constructs a new set of data based on
that it calls the function you know
frequency times X plus Phi and times the
amplitude in it it sets that as the Y
data and then it does this source stop
push notebook and that's sort of the key
here and what we can see is that it
actually responds to this right so if I
let me actually go reload so I'm getting
a lot of interesting little ljs errors
in the notebook today I'm not sure
what's going on there but yeah so now if
I you know what type float it should be
an umpire ray
let's try that one more time not with a
question mark all
anytime that's really weird I'm not sure
what's going on here it's not liking
something about this code although it
should just be straight numpy so I'm not
quite sure but I don't want to debug in
the middle of coal mine normally you can
move those sliders in the pod updates
but it works sort of nicely with ipod
python interactors if you you know what
screw up defining your update function
you can update the data however you want
and then you can push it into the plot
using this source top push notebook so
not quite sure what's going on with my
oh yeah no olk remote so later okay what
about widgets though I mentioned we can
have these nice widgets but again we
want to build to have callbacks so
here's an example that does that this is
that idea that you can if you don't mind
riding just a couple lines of JavaScript
you can actually have some rich
interactions in static documents here I
create a bouquet plot that shows you
know just a line you know it's got a
column data source with you know X and
wine it's just a straight line and then
I've got this JavaScript callback here
and I'm going to go into the details
here because you could see more in the
users guide but i just want to show it
off so know where look here i get my
data source i get out the x and y did
and then I just loop over it and I just
call you know X to the whatever whatever
the value of the slider is you know I
use that as an exponent and so you can
see that when I update the update the
slider it updates the the actual data
that's viewed in the plot right okay
weird I have no idea what that was
complaining about some weird thing I'll
go back and fix it anyway so here you
can see thank you very much so here I
can you know I can select the function
and I can it changes the data and so
that's what that you know the workflow
here is that it's actually computing a
new set of data and then it's calling
this push notebook function to actually
update the data source for the plot you
know in JavaScript it and make the plot
update okay so here again I've added
I've added to slide the way I add the
widget here is I call slider and I give
it a start and step value and maybe a
title and then I put it in this case I
put it in this little vertical layout
but again if you use bouquet dot embed
components you can actually embed it in
whatever you know custom layout you want
and then it just every time I move the
slider it calls this a little bit of
JavaScript and it updates the data so
that's one example another example
when you can do that is with selections
so here this one's a little bit more
sophisticated but it's nice when to sort
of see I've got just some random data
scattered I've got this orange line
drawn at the average one y value right
so whatever the whatever the mean y
value is for all the points that's where
the that's where that orange line gets
drawn and so if I make a selection
though it switches to draw the Y line
wherever you know the average position
of the selected points are and that
includes even with you know multiple
selection too right if I hit shift i can
I can do multiple selections there so
yeah so that's that's a little bit more
jobs so you can certainly do that with a
bouquet server and with Python callbacks
but then you've got to run a server and
but the nice thing here is you know
there's a little bit of JavaScript but
it gets you kind of a lot that you can
do and I get a static document you could
email that to someone and they would be
able to interact with it and have the
tools work just as just as I've shown
here and as I mentioned is we discover
more and more use cases definitely want
to try to encapsulate some of the more
common patterns so you could actually
maybe write a call back in Python you
know that sort of a named object in
Python that sort of does most of this
work for you and reduce that amount of
JavaScript even further and again the
dream one day would be to just be able
to write that callback in Python and
just have it translated automatically so
maybe we could use breath on or pi j s
for that or something something
different but if you think that's
interesting problem and please come talk
to me I'd love to I'd love to
collaborate on that so anyway so there's
some more examples in the users guide go
ahead and go back to adding interactions
here so you can also add interactions
for hover right so here this actually
wanted me required data call back soon
we're going to add a new policy so if
you want to set the the visual policy
for hover you can do that right now
there's a little bit of a call back to
do that but you can see as I you know as
I do it does a horizontal selection as
you move up and down it hovers those
points differently so that's certainly
possible to do here's another example of
using the selection call back all this
does is it copies the data the selected
data points from the data source on one
plot to another so as I you know as I
copy or as I select it they show up in
the other plot you know and you can just
have that work without too much extra
effort so you can imagine doing a lot of
interesting things with that
depending on what your Jo sort a
comfortable comfort level is last
example here show before probably
wrapping up because we're getting right
close to time is it's also possible to
have callbacks that get triggered when
the range changes right so here if i
zoom in to this plot then it actually
triggers a callback that draws the box
on the corresponding plot so i can
actually see you know where we're sort
of this zoom region is and you know i
can move that around and it just follows
around the zoom region and also see that
level of detail down sampling going into
effect on this first block is it about
there's about a four thousand points in
each of those plots so you know it's not
a huge number but it's enough that we
might want to try to make sure the
interactivity is maintained okay so i
think that was about the last example i
wanted to show we're not going to dive
into any more exercise i don't think but
maybe we'll take a few minutes just for
questions and then make sure everyone
has time to get to the next session so
yeah let's go ahead and take questions
yep yeah so the question is how far away
are we from creating images and uh I
really hope at this point it's not we're
going to a couple of months there's a
few different approaches the problem is
there's there's several possible
approaches and none of them or all of
them have fairly significant problems I
mean we had hoped we could maybe just
run everything a node and use like node
canvas which is a chiro box canvas
implementation just pull everything out
you know automatically but bouquet is a
fairly big and complicated library we
haven't gotten it to run in node the
other idea is well maybe we could use
like we just implement a chiro back in
directly that ingests the bouquet jason
and renders and that's certainly doable
but building cairo is you know even with
Conda getting cairo is maybe kind of a
pain and but we'd also that's just work
we have to implement enough of the
rendering back in to render static wats
all over again right so that's probably
what we might end up doing but there are
some new tools I think there are some
new JavaScript libraries that didn't
exist the last time we look at this that
might possibly allow us to get like SVG
from sort of canvas you know they
basically instrument the canvas and they
can spit out SVG and so
maybe fingers crossed but then there's
also intersects things like that math
text discussion right because ideally we
can draw the math text on the canvas
although what happens when a WebGL
canvas and there's it's an open question
but if that doesn't work gonna have to
absolutely positioned divs and then all
of a sudden your unified SVG output is
so there's all these sort of really
unpleasant things intersecting you know
both of those problems sort of
intersecting unpleasant ways and so
we've gotten to a point where we've sort
of exhausted all the other big problems
we can we put it off as long as we can
so it is it is definitely high priority
for us now and so we're going to find
something that hopefully will work in
the vast majority of cases for the short
term and then again the long term plan
is to use matplotlib I mean there's just
been person years worth of investment
into making static you know fantastic
static image generation and SVG and VPS
and PDF and all kinds of formats in
matplotlib so let's just leverage that
but that's you know that's we got to
rely on their timeline and there they're
working on some other good stuff right
now and it's going to be a while so so
yeah short answer may be a few months I
hope I think I've said that before but
this time I I mean it it's definitely a
priority okay good question other
questions yep the story is streaming
that's a really good question so uh
thank you so there's a couple of
different ways to stream data into
bouquet pots if you have streaming data
so the first thing is if you have data
behind some kind of rest api that's
super simple there's something called an
ajax datasource we saw the column
district but there's been called an ajax
data source that you configure basically
the rest endpoint and you can also
configure it with one of these sort of
JavaScript actions to do any kind of
conversion you need and you can just
have that pull data directly to the
client at whatever rate you want or you
can have it do it in response so you
know widgets or whatever you like and
that's so an easy sort of way to do it
in fact the the spectrogram example
basically does something very much like
that it's a rest endpoint it pulls the
data directly into the client and does
some work there so that's one option the
other option is to use the bouquet
server and you can do that today the way
the bouquet is architected is such that
you know when you when you created
Python this pile of you know object
models that represent the visualization
you want a scene graph we call it you
can you direct lee generate a plot from
that or you can push those
up to a bouquet server in the way
bouquet works is that if your view a
plot from the server if the models on
the server change the plot changes and
if the state on the browser changes it
gets mirrored back to the server as well
so that's how you can have things like
selections or buttons trigger you know
further computations on the server and
so that's really cool you can do that
now it's a little bit maybe clunky and
so that's what we're working on making a
lot better in a lot more streamlined I
think we have a very clear vision to
wear that needs to go we just need to
execute and do the work there but you
can do that now so that's another option
for streaming as well try think of as
anything other good comments to make
there to point you out besides the
server in the Ajax datasource part of
the server improvements we're making our
more explicit support for efficient
streaming so for instance actually doing
a pens like right now with the server I
think you have to send their full data
columns and that could maybe be
problematic if your data is just
continually growing and so we're adding
a new layer of interface for instance
for a pending data and maybe doing that
with a truncation if it's appropriate so
anyway lots of good stuff coming in the
time being probably the easiest way to
look at the Ajax a source and there are
some examples of the Ajax data source in
the examples folder in the you know to
get hub repo so i'll point you at those
uncertainly any other any questions you
have we try to be as responsive as we
can on the mailing list on github issues
we try to monitor stack overflow it's
gotten to be a bit of a you know the
chunk of work to monitor all that so
sometimes it takes us longer than we'd
like but we do try to keep on top of
things so any other questions comments
okay well I want to thank thank everyone
for being here I'm sorry yes thank you
Brian thanks for that session that's
right